swimming in general is a very weird
crazy gay Sport and I'm shaving your
body shaving your body Speedos I like
that it's become the Battleground
because no one cares about it either
nobody no one cares about swimming and
at all swimmers have they're ripped they
have great bodies but no one really
cares occasionally in the Olympics you
go oh that's nice but I like that it's
become this you know no one cares right
it's not the thing anyone cares about no
one but what's great is it's this
cultural Battleground where people are
scr and these people we've never heard
from before and never will again sure
are coming out and going I'm a female
swimmer and I deserve respect
outside of this people would have went
just shut the [__] up yeah they would
have said that to us she would have went
unless I I have I'm third ranked in the
100 freestyle and they would have went
shut the [__] up you mean nothing
because they don't but now I think it's
funny it is but I mean I'm probably
saying something so stupid and like base
but like shouldn't you cut your painter
off if you're fully agree and it's more
aerodynamic
that's I don't believe some of these are
you going for time or not yeah all that
drag yes are we going for time I think
some people are unsure if they're gonna
stay the other way oh that's interesting
they're hedging their bets when they're
like I'm detransitioning in case I want
to change my mind later yes wait does
this person take hormones like did this
person I think maybe probably Leah yeah
yeah like she took estrogen for sure
like she's got the hog does she have
tits yeah she has tits are they good
those lats are wild ones but I love that
we're debating this now as a country
like there's going to be a congressman
that comes out soon and goes hey just
cut off the hog if you want to be if you
want to be a female swimmer you got to
cut off your dick yeah you know I mean I
kind of feel like shouldn't there just
be a baseline Criterion for being on the
women's team yeah like okay I understand
you identified what's Leah Thomas height
and weight can you do that she's not
trying at all to look like no like no
trying she's done less work on it than
anyone I've ever seen she literally just
showed up put a bathing cap on right and
a onesie and like I'm a woman that
doesn't seem six one her way is not 132.
no at least a Dylan Mulvaney one is
trying to be a woman although be it a
psychotic one
person yeah what is the origin so
annoying of this per of Dylan so Dylan
was an effeminate gay man who was I
believe on Broadway or something okay a
singer an actor or something like that
and then uh decided to transition and
then did this blog or something where
she was like every day she's like I've
been a girlfriend three days so it
started during coven but you can see
what real effort looks like here yes she
for sure loves it she loves me I mean
some of these guys she's trying she's
trying some of these guys that
transition especially like in their 50s
and 60s you're like yeah
you got to put it into another gear like
this is not there's something about
sitting down with your kid and going if
you're gonna transition you gotta try
you gotta try like this family will
stand behind you but you gotta try yeah
you gotta get a [__] you gotta get tits
you gotta look good
makeup well done I would actually say
the you know some people when they're
aging you're like hey you know just age
right with the face but oh older dudes
who are transitioning I would say start
with the facelift get yourself you have
a big old Basset Hound face you look
like a Droopy Dog that's true like I'm
abroad and you're like yeah it's like a
[__] oil tanker worker it's uh like
you gotta you used to pull this [__] up
shave off a lot of your face like
Caitlyn Jenner did it she did it late in
life but her work looks really because
she spent the money to at least like go
I'm you know I'm trying to like Caitlyn
had I think the right type of this is
the way to get people to get on the side
of trans people she transitioned and
then immediately said I'm against gay
marriage and I'm voting for Donald Trump
and that
that yeah like I don't know I don't know
trans community hasn't tried that like
just try try to be a little more
conservative like why are they not trans
people being like hey I like the cops
yeah
you know what I mean like why aren't
trans people being like actually the
cops serve a vital function in our
society yeah yeah and I like the cops
like why aren't they You Gotta Throw to
get full equality you got to throw some
of your own people yes under under the
bus yeah especially when they've already
been long dead yeah so for me if I
wanted to move in like a nice straight
Community like you people live in sure I
would say something like I'm sure a few
of those people at Stonewall were acting
up yeah yeah you know what I mean a few
of them needed to I get it I get why so
you have to the trans people have to
like first of all they merged with the
fat people which is better trans people
came out and were like they were like
they're like fat act and a lot of them
are fat yeah they have to clean it up
because if game man first look like me
they wouldn't have worked gay men came
out looking athletic better than
everyone sharp and better and then
everyone eased into it and then they
accepted different types of gay men but
like this idea that like people have to
it's like the Sam Smith thing people
like oh people are so transphobic I'm
like you can't be like hey I'm
non-binary and I look like a plumber and
I'm wearing a panties yeah yeah how much
can Americans accept every trans person
should be super hot to begin with to
begin with let's roll out the hot ones
first yes you should you know what we
should all be fooled like you should be
like there's no [__] way right so
really yeah and then be like oh wow get
us on board with that for a while yeah
and then introduce everything well so
yeah so like the swimsuit edition
there's a trans lady on that one yeah
and she kind of works out that blonde
super hot super hot yeah there's a lot
of very hot trans people and we're we're
losing that which is sad and they
shouldn't [__] with Bud Light I think
that was the big mistake with them yeah
it was a disaster don't do that disaster
she's pretty blondly she's got big tits
no not this not this broad that's a
trans that is I don't know if it is but
the one that I know of that they
recently put her on is a blonde woman
okay big cans I think it's just like my
perspective was like Hey when you're
when you're like
I mean convincing no that's Kim Petras
she did the song with Sam Smith yeah I
mean this is the kind that's what I'm
saying I want I like to be to the point
where I go like oh I'd [__] this chick
and then she pulls her dick out and I go
I guess I still will you know like that
that's exactly right you know that
fooled I want to be completely yeah you
want to be thrown yeah you want to be
thrown and I think that is the way to
get especially like if you're talking
about part of the of the country being
transphobic you gotta [__] right
really fool them you got a hundred
percent because I think people are
afraid of teachers turning their kids
into 300 pound trans Communists yeah
maybe they're not worried about their
kids being like hot trans like if if if
if literally you had a meeting and went
they're going trans we can't stop it but
they're gonna be hot I know they're
gonna be hot at least some of the
parents would be like hey yeah I got a
hot trans kid as opposed to like some
fat disgusting trans commune well same
with the non-binaries if the non-binary
community weren't always obese girls
with purple hair yeah piercings I might
be more on board with them too yes or if
those obese girls with purple hair
started coming out and going we don't
need welfare get a [__] job you lazy
piece of [__] then Republicans would
start going uh yeah we disagree with
that they'd start using the pronouns
they'd be like we disagree with them uh
they are making some interesting points
though we do feel the social safety net
can lull people into